welcome back to new rock stars I'm Jani
Piekarski and I hope you have a coin at
the ready for at awesome because we're
talking about The Witcher today season
one this new Netflix series has a ton of
lore lots of rich backstory going into
like centuries of kingdoms rising and
falling so if there were little
political details or timeline confusions
we're gonna clear up anything that you
missed that's what we're here for boiler
warning not only am I gonna break down
everything from this first season but
I'll also go into where the series might
be headed for later seasons all right
let's start with episode one it's called
the ends beginning it's based on the
original short story by on J's of Kowski
that's how I think it's pronounced the
lesser evil we meet Geralt The Witcher
in the midst of a battle with a key
Kimura a monster from Rio Slavic
folklore traditionally an evil female
domestic spirit he rides into bladvic in
to try to collect a monster bounty but
finds the town unfriendly to witcher's
except for ren free and murica run free
shows him kindness and with the line
more and more I find his very franca
she sets up a very Hunchback of Notre
Dom theme of who is the monster and who
is the man next we meet ciri and her
sexy sexy grandparents callumt day of
sintra and aced of Skellig ax during a
game of knucklebones ciri looks off into
space at an empty doorway which we find
out later had just had Geralt in it
shraeger Bor tells Garrett about the
prophecy of the Black Sun and asks him
to kill Ren free the story about Ren
free is kind of like a dark version of
Snow White right down to the evil
stepmother and the Huntsman who tries to
kill her astray gabor also mentions
hulka's rebellious a rebellion led by a
disenfranchised princess who destroyed
mirth the ancient city of mages at a
feast back in Sintra AIST says that he
saw the Wraiths of more hog an omen of
war these are also known as the wild
hunt which comes from Norse mythology in
the lore of The Witcher their spectral
riders in the sky and within The Witcher
saga they turn out to be elves who later
have importance in series story run free
ask Geralt has kill Strega more for her
while he gathers herbs by the river this
is a nod to the importance of alchemy in
The Witcher games she mentions that
Queen kalantay has just won her first
battle at hush bows which is the first
indication that we have different
timelines going on here
Geraldton Ren free our meeting up about
30 years in the past relative to Siri
central loses two nilfgaard and mouse
xscape Rafa see of the Black Sun details
like this appear in every episode to try
to tie the storylines together until
destiny binds them Colette they returns
mortally wounded and we can see that
she's already wearing the sash that
Mouse it picks up and later the Doppler
uses to win over Siri Queen Colette they
execute her final orders mentioning
tamasic
an important set up or the payoff that
Geralt was in sintra this entire time
when Colette they send Syria way here he
taps into her magical powers for the
first time and we hear the sound of a
lion growl which is a reference to Siri
being the lion cub of syndra we hear
this sound effect again which uses her
magic to escape from the black night
back in bladvic in Geralt wakes up from
a prophetic dream where Wren free
predicts the outcome of her ultimatum
reward will be a stone and we see that
after Gerald slaughters Wren free and
her men earning himself some very anti
Witcher xenophobia from Strega boar and
the crowd who call him the butcher of
blacken alright on to episode 2 for Marx
the title reference is the amount of
money that to say a DeVries pays to buy
yennefer from her father chronologically
this is the earliest moment of season 1
yennefer begins the story as a
disfigured peasant girl but experiences
a conduit moment with some bullies that
alerts to say and then brings her to
arrow tuza
Jennifer meets is 'tried a novitiate
from Bernard a school for male mages we
meet yes gear and Posada his name means
buttercup in Polish but in the english
translations and in the games he's known
as dandy-lion
I guess the Netflix series didn't want
us to call him that because they want us
to take him I guess a little more
seriously by the way
that's a penis all of Yuka's skiers
songs are about pre geralt drops his
last coin from his coin purse assignment
he hasn't really been doing well since
bladvic
not a great moniker to have over his
head Jennifer attends a magic lesson
where we first meet her cohort a Tara
tuza including Fran Jilla and Sabrina
from Jilla learns a brutal lesson that
magic requires sacrifice a lesson she
carries forward into her equally brutal
career while yennefer works on lifting
her rock she tries eating her flower
imitating what she saw from history
Visayan notices this and says sometimes
a flower is just a flower this might be
where to say a first suspects that
yennefer is connected with history after
meeting dara in the woods Cyrilla meets
up with a family of racists in turin
refugees who bring up Philip and rules
uprising and general anti elf sentiments
this keeps series storyline connected
with gerelds because Geralt later meets
fill of and rule this family also has a
half-elf servant which is exactly the
fateful Evangel predicts for half else
Carol Tania's gear go to dole plethora
and have an encounter with Torque the
Sylvan who the locals have been mistaken
for a devil did your mother
yes gear learns the truth about elves
being forced out of dole plethora in a
scene that plays out a lot like a high
school student learning about the true
history of Thanksgiving Phil Evangel
tells the truth about the great
cleansing which comes up again later
between history and yennefer
after a lightning catching trial
yennefer reveals to is written that
she's one-quarter elf and her father was
killed in the great cleansing history
teaches her how to use fen wood to
summon untraceable portals and they both
report back to their teachers about what
they learned forgotten arcs
yes Kier composes toss a coin for your
Witcher ignoring everything he just
learned jennifer learns what really
powers arrow to zeal slaves I just kind
of messed up in episode 3 betrayer moon
based on the story titled simply The
Witcher we meet a different Witcher in
tameria this Witcher is introduced while
smoking
foreshadowing his death in a smoke house
as he fights the VUCA black or werewolf
well what they think is of a cop black
the symbol for this episode is the
strigas claw but it also resembles the
amphora from episode 5 fist riga emerges
from the vessel of her mother's womb
Geralt passes a sign that says tomaría
realm of monsters and coward
with a picture of a donkey wearing a
crown this is really similar to King
Midas from Greek mythology who's cursed
to have an ass's ears
the miners mentioned the usurper of milf
guard which places the story after
what's going on in the ennifer episode
because in her story Fergus is still
king of milf guard in arethusa yen and
history had talked about their future
assignments hystyried is supposed to go
to tomaría and yin to aid her we learn
that the girls are magically made pretty
but the bannard boys don't have to be
hence strength ago the mage Triss
Merigold brings Geralt back to the
castle and we learn that the monster is
actually austria darryl suspects the
king foltest
of committing incest with his sister an
accusation that gets Gerald thrown out
once more in a meeting of mages Strega
boar uses his knowledge about Jennifer's
blood to get her sent to milf guard
instead of a turn in this conversation
we also learned that Colette Bey is not
yet queen of sintra so yennefer
storyline is the earliest
chronologically Geralt and Tris find
letters in a music box that confirm the
unfortunate incest theory and today it
meets younger versions of falta Sanada
and yeah he's already got a crush on her
Geralt finally finds out from Lord
ostrich what he did to curse adda and
her child and while he fights this
overgrown abortion yennefer has her own
uterus completely removed on episode 4
of banquets bastards and burials this
one is based on a matter of price for
Geralt stuff and sword of Destiny for
the series death yes gear asks for girls
help out of feast and Sentra because
he's pissed off one too many Lords by
cuckolding them Geralt meets up with his
old friend mouse ik at this feast and he
learns that kolento is trying to marry
her daughter off in order to secure a
strong alliance with the kingdom of
Skellig ax where her future husband aced
turns out to be from we go to the bro
Kalon forest with Siri and there are
surprisingly few Bros in broeckel on
their our dryads there and they
explained to ciri the history of men
destroying what existed on the continent
before them including
force like Brooklyn and including
families of elves like Dara's scarole
gets tied up deeper and deeper into the
politics of this feast and hey fun fact
manticores only have one stinger
jennifer has been a court for thirty
years now she escorts Queen Callas of a
turn whom she resents for being a
barring vessel but unfortunately for
Calais those kids aren't male so the
king sends an assassin and hell monster
after them to kill her
yes Kier sings another song about his
horn which rises in the morn and : thay
talks to Geralt about how she resents
male tradition the feast is interrupted
by Lord yon of airlin vault or Dooney
but this guy's got a lot of aliases we
might learn more about that later
who claims the law of surprise in which
favors like saving a life are paid by
that which you have but do not know you
have in this case the late King Ritter's
future daughter pavetta yennefer
attempts to save Queen callouses baby
but just as she tries to jump through a
portal to safety the assassin throws a
knife that cuts straight through her and
kills the baby Cirie has a nightmare
where she has literal blood on her hands
as she watches elves have their ears cut
off this prompts her to drink the water
of broeckel on so that she can forget
the past of her family back in the feast
Dooney and pathetic availed after Geralt
saves Juni's life Geralt claims law of
surprise just like Dooney did and just
like Dooney did earns a child of
surprise this time ciri mouseykin grabs
columbus sash as he's dragged out of
sintra okay before I continue
thanks to Skillshare for sponsoring this
video make 2020 a year where you explore
new skills deep in existing passions and
get lost in creativity with skill shares
online classes what you find just might
surprise and inspire you skill share is
an online learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
Skillshare offers classes designed for
real life so you can move your creative
journey forward without putting life on
hold you can learn and grow with short
classes that fit your busy routine they
have classes and topics new rockstars
fans will enjoy like animation film and
video and creative writing some pluses
I'm going to check out include how to
make dopes low-budget films and Colour
masterclass simple steps to create vivid
art school share is also incredibly
affordable to join especially when you
compare it to pricey in-person classes
and workshops an annual subscription is
less than $10 a month click the link in
the description to get two free months
of premium membership and explore your
creativity alright let's move on to
episode 5 bottled appetites
the nilfgaardian 'z transport Masek and
cage made of dimmer idiom a medal from
the games that suppresses magic in the
title card we see two bodies intertwined
to make the symbol of the amphora that
yennefer paints on her navel later in
the episode one body is male Geralt the
other is female yennefer bound together
by the magic of the gym
yennefer seats fertility treatments and
she's surrounded by our glasses as she
tries to turn back the clock in order to
make money for her treatments she sets
up her own sorcery shop with lots of
overturned horseshoes around the
superstition about horseshoes over a
doorway comes from the story of Saint
Dunstan and the devil horseshoes up
that's good luck horseshoes down that's
some wicked stuff going down
according to yes gear it's been about
five years since the Feast of sintra
which we find out from - Seiya later in
the episode mentioning that the super of
milk guard has been overthrown Geralt
struggles to sleep due to his defiance
of destiny with series so he seeks to
find a JIT and when he catches it
it marks wishes with cuts on his arm he
looks to find help for your skier and is
directed towards Jennifer Jennifer and
Gerald negotiate a bargain in Jennifer's
order room surrounded by imagery of very
very phallic words kumquat yennefer
cures yes Kier in exchange for Gerald's
company and she finally succeeds in
enchanting him after distracting him
with the scent of lilac and gooseberries
this is a reference to the name of a
quest in the witcher 3 game Jennifer
tries to capture the gin but Geralt
saves her with his final wish by asking
for something that will bind her destiny
with his and now that he's playing with
destiny instead of against it Geralt
finally gets a good night's rest dopler
mouse' cause up and broeckel on to pick
up cirilla and the credits roll with the
song the last rose of sintra blir except
the song echo the notion that the queen
of the dryads passed along to Cirie
about the sort of destiny having two
edges it says her path could lead to
happiness or the end of times for all
now let's move on to episode six rare
species Geralt joins a dragon hunt with
boar ch3 jackdaws and his traveling
companions taya and veía who asked him
to join the quest they explained that
his have urn that they're supposed to
hunt a dragon in front of a fireplace
that looks just like the gaping maw of a
dragon with fire inside yes gear
describes Tara as Sarah Kane Ian's
zarok Kania is a land known for three
things dragon Colts rare species and
warrior women check check and check
yennefer comments on you a skiers
appearance saying the crow's feet are
new and it's really cute that she's
pretending like anybody has aged in this
series for reference this is at most
seven years since the incident of the
gym the gin Siddhant yes gear encounters
arica along the path and it follows him
back to a group fun fact according to
The Witcher lore Henriques are even more
rare than dragons and look at this rare
specimen he's incredible take a second
to appreciate and he's dead sir [ __ ]
of dennis lay killed him thanks Ike well
I guess he gets what's coming to her
who's relieving his bones Cirie and Dara
are escorted by Doppler Masek who keeps
touching series hair he did the same
thing when they reunited at the end of
Episode five and I think this is a
foreshadow that he's going to turn into
her in the background of this shot you
can see a monolith in the distance I
couldn't find much information about
these in the lore but they are all over
the place in this series if you have
theories comment below
after apparently losing Borch taya and
their yin and geralt makeup and seem to
truly reconcile back there's always
fruit when they have sex I think this is
probably a negative juxtaposition with
their own lack of fertility Jennifer and
Geralt discover that not only is bore
still alive but he's a dragon named
villian treat in math which in Elder
means three black birds his pseudonym
Borch three jackdaws also describes
three black birds they protect fortune
his egg from the Reavers but then we get
three consecutive breakups taro breaks
up with ciri yennefer breaks up with
Geralt when she finds out about his wish
to the Jin and Geralt breaks up with the
S gear because he's just a little too
annoying I guess you could say that
cahier we finally get a name for this
black knight broke up with the Doppler
too and broke up with a bunch of people
in a bakery breakups are hard man I get
it
it's tough let's move on to Episode
seven before a fall theory tries to make
her way to Skellig ax to find refuge
among her grandfather's family and when
Geralt realizes that nilfgaard is
marching north he seeks to make sure
that his child surprise is safe kalenna
is fear of her granddaughter's destiny
makes her do awful things she wouldn't
do otherwise
like in Oedipus Rex or the prophecy of
Saturn's children from Greek mythology
her attempts to avoid destiny only
guarantee it she tries to have Geralt
assassinated and so he loses his trust
in her ability to protect cirilla
syria's offered help by what turn
out to be the most forgiving woman in
history and in return Siri steals this
woman's horse clop
I think Clem paid tries to pull the old
switcheroo on Geralt but through an act
of destiny
Gerald gets wise it's not wise enough to
avoid getting trapped in the gatekeeper
enter vill go forth of Roggeveen he
stalks yennefer into returning to arrow
to zou where she checks out her old
stomping grounds and teaches some girls
who had botany is really about thanks
rectoress piccoli at one point she sees
a reflection of her old self in the
mirror this moment reflects the moment
in episode 3 when to say a shows her
what she would look like in the future
the mages have a meeting to discuss what
ought to be done about nilfgaard and
there's a recurring artistic motif
around arrow tuza of these islamic
geometries they're beautiful and
complicated patterns but they also
reinforce the idea that air tuza deals
in the arcane and the abstract so
they're bound not to vote to interfere
the fall of sintra plays out again but
this time with Geralt and we catch up
with Siri talking to her horse now
that's what I call destiny I talk to my
horse
Ceres attacked by some ragtag Centrum's
and her magical powers activate we end
the second episode in a row with this
prophecy about the axe and the sword
this is it Lin's prophecy if Flynn was
an elven prophetess who predicted the
end of times in an Ice Age and a
bloodbath fun lady and finally we get to
episode much more this episode's title
is a reference to the short story that
episodes 7 and 8 are based off of
something more daryl runs into a farmer
named yurga who's cleaning up the dead
center in refugees Geralt gets bitten by
a necrophagous spends the rest of the
episode tripping balls the woman from
the market who we later learn is York
his wife Zola finds Siri in the middle
of a field and takes her home as the
camera zooms out we see that the blast
pattern in the surrounding water
resembles the amphora symbol once again
Siri is a vessel for great power which
she released a bit of last night the
say--is rebel mages make a plan to
defend the stronghold at sodden from the
milf Guardians until the kingdoms of the
north being led by focus of Samaria can
bring down their armies an officer tries
to convince cahier to wait for
reinforcements before trying to take the
mages stronghold but thinking that Syria
has crossed the river to the north he
decides that he can't let her get away
ironically as we find out in the next
scene where ciri watches from Djilas
attack on sodden she's clearly still on
the same side of the river as them we
get to see a lot of cool fighting
between mages but I want to zoom in on
these two items that from Jilla summons
one is a nifty box of mind-control worms
but the other a little bit harder to
track through the battle is a bag of de
Meridian which Fran Jilla uses to
incapacitate to say his powers did I
miss him
Geralt season hears people from his past
we see the druid healer vasana gerelds
mother how the sena sorceress was able
to conceive Geralt remains unclear but
she abandons him leaving him to be found
by vesemir The Witcher Vicente appears
possibly only in a dream to heal Geralt
when he recognizes her he confronts her
about how horrible the trials of
becoming a Witcher were specifically the
trial of grass in which mortal men are
mutated into becoming witchers this is
the trial that only 3 out of 10 PI
survived when Geralt wakes up
juergen thanks him for saving his life
and offers the law of surprise as
payment the mages nearly lose the battle
all of them dead or injured but to say
it gives you Anna for a touching pep
talk and tells her this calls back to
when yennefer didn't need a bottle to
harness the power of lightning but it
also ties into all of the vessel imagery
throughout the series they say is
telling you nifer to finally unleash
everything that she has bottled up
inside
yennefer scorches the remaining milf
guardians just in time for king
foltest's to show up with the northern
armies the day is saved but jennifer has
disappeared the following morning
Geraldton ciri finally reunite running
into each others arms but with a
continent at war and five novels left to
explore this is hardly a happily ever
after comment below with your thoughts
and you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at Dani purcahse make sure you
follow new rock stars for more
breakdowns and theories and be sure to
check out this channels newest show the
big question in which Philip and Eric
give you too much information about
nerdy topics this week's episodes gonna
be about who Emperor Palpatine might
have had sex with yummy I think I heard
someone saying kumquat so I'm just gonna
cut it right here see you next time
[Music]